[Music]
nevada gas prices are among the highest
in the country this labor day weekend
but experts say it isn't going to stop
people from loading up and hitting the
road bianca holman reports
we had travel points and the drive out
isn't so bad but we don't want to spend
eight hours in the car driving back
while folks like greg saunders from
orange county california flew into town
this labor day weekend others decided to
hit the highways las vegas is definitely
a top destination this holiday ever
since uh covert 19 restrictions began to
be loosened around mid-march we've seen
that the the road trip and people taken
to their cars and hitting the road is
has been extremely popular but before
coasting on the road drivers have to
fill up and you may have noticed the
increase at the pump yes gas prices are
higher than they've been in the last
several years um but that doesn't
typically deter someone from taking a
trip uh is what we've learned it they
they may cut corners maybe stay at a
more budget friendly hotel you know eat
out at less expensive restaurants since
demand is high gas prices reflected
prices range from four dollars for
regular to 441 for premium gas according
to aaa once labor day is over that's
kind of the last big hurrah for uh
demand uh so we expect after labor day
gas prices should start to come down uh
come october uh you know uh refineries
switch to a less expensive form of
gasoline so it's less expensive to
produce so there should be some relief
and if you're visiting from southern
california remember to give yourself
extra time when you hit the 15 out of
las vegas you can expect delays bianca
holman 8 news now